the city that never sleeps is waking up
to a new reality late on Sunday night
the mayor of New York tweeted that
nightclubs cinemas theaters and concert
venues in the city must close
restaurants conserve take away food only
and then the mayor of Los Angeles
announced the same two of the world's
biggest cities are bracing themselves
for the second day running Donald Trump
gave a live press conference from the
White House minutes earlier the US
Federal Reserve had cut interest rates
to almost zero it's really good news
it's really great for our country it's
something that we're very happy and then
the president in his own style urged
Americans not to panic by food I would
like to say that people shouldn't go out
and buy we're gonna all be great we're
gonna be so good we're gonna do what's
happened with the Fed is phenomenal is
what's happening with all of these
incredible companies is phenomenal is
but you don't have to buy so much take
it easy just relax do they keep this
social isolation thing late on Sunday
evening the coronavirus crisis dominated
the first half of the Democratic
presidential debate one of these men
will challenge Donald Trump for the
presidency later this year both sought
to paint themselves as the candidate to
calm a nation on edge firstly we have
got to do whether or not on president
it's the shot this president up right
now because he is undermining the
doctors and the scientists who are
trying to help the American people it is
unacceptable to him to be blabbering
with unfactual information which is
confusing the general public this is
bigger than any one of us this is calls
for a national rallying to everybody
move together
yeah the last flights from Europe are
landing in the United States with
Americans desperate to get home whilst
they still can they're arriving back
into a country not sure what to do with
them it's chaos at some airports
passengers are having to stand
side-by-side in queues for hours waiting
to be screened there are long queues to
at drive-through testing centers and the
expectation is that the number of
sufferers in America will rise
dramatically as more results come back
in the coming days the public advice
from the White House so far has been at
times confusing and even dismissive but
after a slow start coronavirus is
beginning to have a greater effect on
everyday life here and the president is
realizing that Alister funcle' Sky News
Washington